[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to the very first
thousand dollar national chest day
Invitational Tournament this is intense
chess we will be your host for this
event my name is Caleb Denby famous for
crushing Jonathan and the April all and
match and I'm joined by the wonderful
Grandmaster Pepe cuenca I kill it needs
no introduction I'm doing quite well I'm
excited for this event it's shaping up
to be one of the most fun one of the
most intense chess tournaments we've
seen yeah me too it's gonna be a lot of
fun like the tank control it's one
minute and ten seconds delayed right yes
it's a crazy time control and why don't
we take a look at some of those
specifics for this format here so there
are eight players in this tournament it
is a single elimination bracket if you
lose one game you are out the time
control is very unique Mike comer came
up with this one game in one minute with
a 10 second delay so you have just one
minute in your time bank and then if you
spend more than 10 seconds on any turn
you're chipping away at that time
forever okay no getting it back if the
players were to draw they're actually
going to quite a crazy tie break system
it is going to be an Armageddon match
where white only has one second on the
clock that is to say no time essentially
in his time bank with a 10 second delay
and black gets to or sorry wake it's 2
seconds to finish yeah and then black
gets just one second in his time bank
time bank with the 10 second delay and
of course draw odds for the Armageddon
game exactly so it's gonna be crazy yes
it'll be very very intense if we see any
tie breaks happen today well why don't
we take a look at who's actually playing
in this to get to here and it looks like
we have some surprises yeah we'll get to
that of course
Jonathan's trance chest launched himself
into chess fame by drawing Hikaru
Nakamura in a Simon
Arjun hurry hey Chess Club local has
probably won a scholastic tournament at
some point you might know him he's very
strong he's meaning my lectures I mean
he sees everything so yeah famous on
YouTube of course for being the kid in
the audience who gets everything
right all the time yeah Dennis Larew the
2017 mid-atlantic mixed doubles champion
not to be trifled with and it looks like
his arch nemesis tournament he's Biggs
perfect Spanish yes that is the Spanish
speaker of the club yeah and of course
Dennis's arch nemesis Michael
Pugachev who of course defeated Dennis
LaRue in one of the previous blitz
bounties that we had here on the YouTube
channel so that'll be a rivalry to look
out for the favorite of the tournament
is national master julienne Pro Lake oh
of course the 2019 Archbishop's board
for MVP in the Pro chesley Wow
that team calling out to to California
and getting the job done winning it all
this year
Tracy Stewart is also in this tournament
she is very cool
of course quote/unquote Grand Master Ken
West who of course famously lost the
World Championship match in 1938 to
Mikhail Botvinnik don't feel the need to
look up that tournament just trust us on
that one and then here's the surprise
the eighth player in this tournament is
a total mystery mystery mummy my sister
got me through for cookie Magnus it
could be Bobby playing maybe uh you know
magnets not having the best Isle of Man
tournament yeah excited to the game so
maybe I just will be draw and then come
here and then enjoy saying Louise means
to me this could be anybody who knows
well with that introduction why don't we
take a look at who these players are
actually squaring off against in this
first round of eliminations Jonathan
strands will be fated facing Arjun Perry
in round one I want to see you that much
yeah I think this is going to be one of
the most interesting one of the most
competitive matches of the entire
tournament exactly after we get done
with that one Dennis LaRue will be
facing his rival immediately in Michael
pugachev Julian pearl Aiko will have to
take down Tracy Stewart and her coolness
in the other half of the bracket and
then Ken West has no idea who his
opponent is nobody does it is a mystery
so Ken West you know perhaps not going
to be very prepared for whatever we
throw at him here yeah welcome I think
that's quite enough introduction for you
guys why don't we get down to business
and here to introduce the players and
get everything kicked off is Mike comer
in our tournament Hall intense chess
what a game it's a game like no other
and we got our full cast of YouTube
characters to help play it out tonight
live on the YouTube happy national chest
day all you guys and we got co-creator
of intense just Jonathan trots the club
manager playing ad journ who will be
victorious adjourn started up alright
here we see the players shake hands
origins starting the clock I think Arjun
yeah bit of a tactical play they're
trying to start the clock before Queens
gambit alright d-4d Johnson no stranger
to the nihms oh but aren't you chooses
the qgd instead it's gonna take let's
see he goes for the semi ty rush no it
goes for it takes d5 knowledge of g5
pinning this knight on f6 you should be
seven and III nobody you want to go here
with Bishop d3 not g3 - and then in the
future try to push the pawns in the
center with f3 on e4
yes that's a kind of the most critical
line these days is delaying this
developing of the night on g1 and bring
it to e2 other than the most natural
square on f3 and now for example after
Queen c2 then you will be threatened to
take an F 687 so that's why you have to
go eight six and then maybe in a really
aggressive style you can go h4 actually
but Jonathan is not in that mood and
then he goes for Bishop H for keeping
things under control
neither player dipping into the that
time Bank just yet playing on the 10th
second place in this opening yeah I
don't like this Bishop T for more
because then after f3 actually that's
part of the plan for white here so f3
and then you can go to age 5 since g4
actually almost wins the game so but
instead in the Jonathan went for 93 to
the more solid approach no but L rush
yeah I'll do that at any point yeah and
after f3 you have also this f2 square
for the Bishop to protect III in case
you need it and now you gotta go to e6 I
guess that's the only square for your
Bishop
after Bishop h5 again g4 could be a
problem in the future so we should be
six and then probably even long castle
looks interesting in order to go all-in
on the kingside shore alone castle g4
group t1 g5 and checkmate yeah
historically going all-in has not worked
out well for Jonathan now and here we
see actually Knight f4 the truth is a
little bit strange to my eyes I would
have liked to see White Castle one way
or the other and then get this play in
the center go exactly okay chief is not
winning of course because you got the
intermediate move Knight takes c6
attacking the Queen so no problems for
black here let's see what black task now
maybe could go rook e8 and not affect
something like this but I still like a
Jonathan's position
definitely and remember Arjun Arjun
right Arjun Arjun has only 36 seconds or
writing his clock so I should hurry
dipping deep into that time bag that is
time that he will not get back 5
breaking in the center move I like it
maybe also threatening some kind of c4
ideas or she takes d4 is there enough
control of the d5 pawn for black to get
away with this yeah I think so whoa
because Bishop f6 Knight takes f6 or no
problem
yeah looks okay so no Johnson not
worried about c4 Argan yeah so this is
forcing both players to end up with an
isolated Queen and only 30 seconds for
both and now Queen b6 I guess you can
net that with Bishop f2 this Bishop on
f2 is perfectly placed and I don't know
how black is gonna put more pressure on
the d4 pawn maybe some 98 and 96 ideas
but they look to me kind of slow so 90
xe6
F takes and then you're gonna protect
that pawn on d4 and Johnathan has the
bishop per and then there's some
pressure on e6 as well right wing if -
this was a little bit strange I like
this move the bishop on h4 is doing not
much now Luke a e8 and the knight h5
could be an idea for black to trade the
dark squares and bishops perhaps even a
5 ideas might come on the board exactly
exactly and if I are after detects it
five days Bishop and c5 we have the
Queen now protecting ETA putting very
solid Chester yeah 81 more protection at
blacks and blacks position is definitely
improving here yep I liked your idea now
this e5 mean it looks dangerous why not
also that has to take care about the
bishop g6 so something like this could
be dangerous for black at some point you
got root key seven and no problems okay
you're gonna move and the time he's not
gonna get back 14 yeah ten seconds Andy
five on the decisive strike in the
center and now you can't take on e5
because there's a Bishop c5 women to
gaming the spot so don't take it
Jonathan what will he do there's Bishop
g6 Ricky 7 but then the same problems
they're not going away
also Knight takes d5 could be a
monstrous move that's a good move Arjun
takes this free pawn on d4 yeah and then
now the e5 square is available for this
d7 9 so now 95 looks good to me but also
the d4 pawn is hanging so maybe you had
to protect it but before you want to
take that I'll play Bishop c5 after you
capture yeah that's true
so I could take it with my queen but
then after Queen takes a for Knight
takes e4 Knight takes c3 looks women
almost but Luke only one is protected
from 8 for bishops I can tell Bishop c5
yeah oh I don't know ok there give me
some h1 so Jenny nothin but now the B
two ponies hanging so maybe is going for
D 3 D 3 10 seconds for Arjun 22 for
Jonathan yes to move you're gonna move
Bishop stations now a d3 is a real
threat so you had to do something maybe
Queen g3 removing the Queen for this
diagonal I don't know man
this is getting crazy so do you want to
take the pawn on d4 I don't know sure
because knight c6 and there's a lot of
pressure 15 seconds for Jennifer come on
Johnny
I'm dealing Bishop takes rook takes you
have to play quickly origin quickly or
d3 even I don't
94 is actually a real threat followed by
Knight to e3 checking this truck on d1
93 I like Knight g4 now Lala 94 but
maybe Queen c2 intending to go Queen 8 7
let's say 94 is coming on I'd say 44 the
same idea coming to e3 what to do about
Queen c2
yeah Queen c2 looks good on the board
now Queen 8 7 but it's not me
so Queen a7 just skinned up 7 and
nothing happens but it really scares me
rook takes you 1 you're gonna take it me
setting that delay clock yeah and maybe
Knight e3 and nothing happens screen 8 7
King f7 because if sacrificing a whole
pond but could be a good idea because
stuff that takes takes takes Dan Black
has least possible on d4 Wow Bishop b4
that's interesting move I'm a fan of the
type of chess where my opponent attacks
my piece I move it out of the way
yeah Bishop b4 okay I mean they couldn't
actually move denied because the other
one c5 was hanging so maybe what's the
second Johnny he moves with more seconds
on his clock
I'm dang now 93 must be coming yeah 93
or 95 to protect g6 he goes from 93 and
then maybe it's time to take that pawn
to g6 maybe six but D pawn is looking
quite close still it's not that easy to
push it because the bishop the light
squared bishop is doing a fantastic job
over there
King g7 just go back to d3 block
everything and then bring the King to
the center there has to be Jonathan's
idea four seconds in the clock he looks
so calm man I'm having a heart attack
here ready
maybe Bishop c3 4 black just block the
files I think I like white now because
Qing Chuang Qian f2 and then I could
start a pawn storm on the Kings side I
got three versus one and these pawns
might come down the board
yeah Arjun with that slight time edge
but he seems to be thinking here yeah no
sign of making a move this could be
close to a draw actually rook d7 I don't
understand this move I really like the
rook on the f5 because there was there
were some Knight g4 ideas kin f7 but he
is planning to bring the key into the
center four seconds Jonatan come on man
and he has to move 95 you're offering a
trade free an opposite color bishops
black can take the e-file now yeah he's
stuck in the rookies 7 margin looking a
little shaky there perhaps the pressure
is getting to them in this intense chess
format
yeah maybe ship d3 I'm Group D one looks
like a fortress York d1 is played
let me see Bishop c3 c3 and then Bishop
d3 I'm maybe gg3
f4 g4 Wow ah but now the dark square is
just slightly weak this King might
invade if if black isn't earth white
isn't careful h4 maybe white Spanish
Bishop d3 young f4 g5 and then there's
also a spawns f4 now come on King g3
allows rookies really is coming Thank
You 3 3 on the board's top enough for
just two more seconds for whites 7
seconds actually Bishop before threatens
checkmate in one move we should be 4 4
to Bishop d6 but he doesn't say it goes
for drew Keefe I don't like this
stopping g5 hopping - maybe roopd want
to go G font check Bishop a5 good move -
no g5 is coming when ya know just about
these pawns are pushing yeah it's got an
advantage now King g7 still not easy we
should teach you check good move on the
check Rick h7 is coming for white yes ok
7 like has to push this deep on maybe
but then there's Rick do you want oh
he's gonna blunder the rope no root of 7
ok 7 kingi aids yet kingi a rook takes
f7 I think King f8 is this choice yeah
it's better to be in the dark squares
maybe
attacking the bishop bishop moves I'm
now actually d3 followed by Brooke f4
could be an idiot g6 is coming oh man
rook g7 c7 that's not that easy to push
yeah the black Bishop preventing that
white came from coming to g5 mm-hmm f4
f4 clearing the way
no maybe d4 d3 to put the bishop on d4
and then to stop all those white pawns
argent makes a move but now Bishop d3
great move
now 760 King f6 if rook F 8 there's King
e7 yeah go back
f5 King f6 again
f5 on the board but now the Kings path
is cut off exactly this position needs
to get to the day to the h8 diagonal
though to stop these pawns Michelin
eatery is doing a fantastic job
preventing white-skinned to come through
now route c7 contemplate no black spawns
on d4 are not so non-threatening anymore
why don't you come down the board yeah
we should be fine two seconds on the
clock for John Wow I think black has to
keep the rook on the seventh front
because you're gonna protect g7 + f7 and
e7 or the whites rook f8 followed by
druker 7 would be winning so six seconds
5 seconds here I think that's a blunder
because now look at seven okay seven you
have to go back and then you can push FC
that's six wheels women there's Ritchie
to check she took in a 5-4 now the king
of SU check King e6 oh geez hon is
coming oh my god margin Luke takes a
sudden probably oh come on Jonathan -
station page six maybe needed to guard
this at faith square maybe Bishop g5 now
Bishop g5 there's a definite on Bishop
d3 wins now looking it followed by
Bishop d3 is actually a real threat
rook h6 are you try to stop it good move
come on six
Ritchie's a good scientist look and
jonathan is winning with two seconds on
the clock Jew six I'm alkene f7 just
Waits rook a7 even they should be born
into take this punch Jake and ever say
anything about sine f8 is coming argent
rides Bishop h6 he still has this D pawn
the rook is a little bit offsides d3 he
pushes he's pushing route da then come
back did you want come on oh yes but no
just Queens and yes we can come back to
f1 and is already the game Arjun pushes
but he's just a move too slow and
Jonathan has this one firmly in hand now
with just 2 seconds on the clock a
highly competitive game there from
Jonathan
in arginine a strong showing from our
gym and urgent soil like a great suit
jacket yeah yeah yeah
Arjun came came ready to be DHS
professional he's really strong I mean
how is he
he should be less than 10 no I think
he's around 10 okay use around him I
don't know actually it's arjan's been
coming to the Chess Club for a long time
mm-hmm but here we see Jonathan strands
expanses from the extreme eight into the
Furious four and with that up next is
going to be a highly anticipated matchup
everybody wanted a rematch of this game
now Dennis threw against Michael
Pugachev they played before they have
played before and it highly watched
highly sensationalized YouTube event the
Blitz bounty yes I was doing commentary
in this okay I believe we've been yes
you might have been doing the one on
Jacob Sanders oh I believe though we are
going to have a quick interview with
Jonathan strands back in our tournament
area with Michael comer all right I'm
here with the winner Jonathan trance
also the co-creator of intense chess so
I have to ask you did you think when he
puts you in check at the very end there
with the rook that you were checkmated
okay so adjourn put up a heck of a fight
but it was great do you think that you
know such we created this like two years
ago that you had a an edge over
adjourned
sure I don't know if I'm taking the mic
but I'm just taking the mic yeah no I
thought this would be interesting I
thought it would play a lot more like a
rapid game actually but really at some
point I don't know where the time is
going it's just somehow it's leaking
leaking and then at some point it feels
just like a blitz game it doesn't feel
like a real rapid game if this was game
in ten minutes
it feels just like you got to go way
faster than that yeah what's interesting
about this format is when you're using
the shot clock when you're using that
ten seconds ten nine eight seven it
seems like you have all the time in the
world and then once you start using your
time Bank it just evaporates right where
to go yeah that's exactly how it felt at
some point it just
became a blitz game and I got kind of
lucky that I was able to help lay him
there at the end well good luck in the
rest of your matches you'll be playing
the winner of Pugachev against Dennis
fluru which will be coming up next all
right well we're back here in the studio
of course this next matchup well first
big congratulations to Jonathan the
beaded argent Perry and what was a very
close match and argent definitely not
the easiest opponent for Jonathan
exactly yeah really strong and then it
was a great fight yeah yes well we do
have a lot to look forward to a lot to
look forward to here today that one's
just game one of seven in the single
elimination tournament of course this
first place prize is no joke five
hundred dollars you know the one
thousand dollar total prizes these
players are playing for a lot as well as
of course you know the bragging rights
on this YouTube channel well our next
matchup is going to be between the one
and only
Dennis Larew and Mike mukacheve like
we've been saying these players have
played before Michael did manage to
defeat Dennis in their berths bounty
matchup but Dennis you know he's hungry
you know he's looking he's looking for a
match victory here I don't know yet if
we're ready to go back so yeah
let's go over to the tournament hall
with Mike comer where he can introduce
this next round all right here we go the
rematch of the blitz bounty that what
Dennis LaRue does not want to remember
but let's see if he can even the score
here in the intense chess format on your
mark get set pugachov dope all right we
see the handshake there from the players
Dennis starts with E 4 E 5 g 4 is this
gambit done C 3 how many people take on
d4 96 should it be the best move
definitely but ok
Knight a 3 he keeps insisting in this
gambit on d5 he's stretching the center
already we could reach an isolated pawn
structure after it takes d5 context a
584 and dennis is already waving his
hands around now you look so nervous
today he 5 5 is his choice
wow he wants to take down d4 and her
have a nice Center let's see if black
finally takes tap on on c3 I would take
it without blinking I think it's time
and Michael does capture and after
Knight takes is there a d4 move from
black yeah there could be this d4 mover
also be should be six but he goes for d4
attack in this night maybe not b5
intending to go for Knight ext4 in the
next move or Knight e4 bringing the
knight to the center
let's see ideas maybe a Bishop g4 here I
don't know
v5 and then as you say Bishop g4 looks
interesting could be an idea
Michael raises his hand and it comes
back down yeah you could play Bishop c4
in those positions f7 looks a little bit
weak Michael actually already burning
into that shot clock here with just 51
seconds left on his clock yeah and once
you once you use this time you never get
it back exactly stock playing on that
10-second delay that action clock is
Mike comer said does the light thing is
extremely tricky Europe we never play
with this delay we play with increment
and it's completely different
yes Kermit you build that time back up
but exact Mike actually already using
almost half of his time here in the
opening yes so just see Bishop e6 enough
tonight XD for there could be some
Bishop b4 that could be very very
dangerous but he doesn't see that
Michael takes quickly yeah now if you
take with the night again you should be
for almost wins so let's see what this
does play okay visual area for check
blink King e to only move there surprise
there Bishop d2 we take c4 we need for
tackling maybe maybe that's the vibes
yeah yeah then Bishop d2 is also
possible I don't think Dennis saw this
coming however though he might play just
king e - trying to keep his piece look
so difficult the position already so
muddy
Michael catching back up on that clock
here Dennis doesn't know what to do he
does play King E - oh there's Bishop c4
check that's a brave King Bishop c4 in
this game is maybe Bishop King III or
something I'm gonna be 25 f4 still not
that clear you win the game with the
black pieces but of course this should
be completely crushing there's still
Quinn a4 check thread stuff
to look out for you can see black easily
losing a piece here exactly I'm almost
off to keep me three night the night
when the night comes to e7 also there
some check some d5 and on f5 so tennis
already down to 20 seconds though he has
to make a move
keep your f3 this is not the move to
think about you don't have to go that's
a brave kid
it wants to check Nate he's opponent
with a kid it's both these players
putting on their poker faces here but I
think they are nervous there's no time
for poker faces here as you said the
bishop on c4 is attacked queen a4 check
is threatened how can black solve all of
his problems he takes on f1 yeah and
then protects and maybe Bishop c5
pinning this knight on d4 looks
extremely natural to me he's reaching
for the Queen
yeah maybe Queen g5 f4 and then he wants
to take on g2 that could be also a
possibility so T sub C 5 the most
natural and then after 97 there you are
threatening Knight f5 so this King might
move again Queen a4 check one check two
zero Michael adjust the piece c6 simply
c6 looks good even kina faked c6 and I
don't know what you're gonna do now
rooty one great will fade after 97 king
e to the King can come back to f1 and g1
game and then constantly like hidden gem
whoops yes all according to plan for
Dennis
Queenie seven on the board hitting this
ePHI pawn a for Dennis plays F for
supporting it but yes at the cost of
more King safety not if 6x6 on the board
using the fact that there's a pin there
on the e-file kina 3 maybe King I think
move like 10 times akin
floating around yeah no worries at all
besides I saw there's some Knight a5
idea now for a way coming into d6 95 and
maybe Knight f5 here not a 5 yes could
be a maniac because then g7 is also
hanging so you cannot go actually Wow
night-night 66 what an idea from Dennis
3 removing the defender baby you're
gonna go here Queen d7 I don't know
Queen d7 pinning this Nocturne on c6
because you take on c6 then quit takes
c6 definitely with the quints the game's
on the spot so probably Queen d7 it's
the only move here what can we even do I
don't know I have to try b4 maybe yeah
maybe your queen I don't know Quincy for
stun see folks that work in there maybe
we can see for after Queen d7 but this
is extremely difficult to calculate with
seven seconds nine applause you got a
real Queen d7 - my god out of come on
man finds Queen d7 three seconds on his
clock Dennis down to 11 seconds Oh Luke
takes T not Queen takes rook with check
and this is just a piece up and the
pieces are flying rook takes c5 and now
Dennis LaRue up a piece against his arch
nemesis ten-second delay can he convert
simply develop the bishop yep Bishop to
e3 he goes pawn grabbing I mean one
important thing is not to get too
nervous now because he is very late
there's no reason to get crazy like he's
doing just play slowly defend your pawns
he throws in a check and then there's
almost checkmate now with 86 F 3 F 3 g4
maybe P 46 that's a checkmate threat so
that's with f5 to follow g4 f5 is
checkmate yes no I 5 because no [ __ ]
to me 5 King g6 then there's at 5 kingi
securities exactly so yeah this is one
either way f5 if check oh he doesn't see
f5 no giving him a flight score still f5
f6 f king f5 you could have gone back to
87 only move only move only move no whoa
take Dylan 11 seconds on the clock for
Dennis plenty of time to secure this win
if he doesn't get in his own head here
88 and now f6 pinning the pawn takes e5
there's your takes g7 yeah and you're
gonna take a min King h8 Oh Liam off
perhaps Michael goes for some stale
matrix yes
rook g5 good move trying to treat
everything f7 now there's Luke g8 so
rook f6 check and then look at five
gasps five
oh he's gonna be play legal move oh no
that's no good
No oh my god she was shouting so you
wouldn't hear me
players aren't that far away oh my
goodness Dennis Dennis had it all he had
it all and then he plays f8 Queen an
illegal move well he's in check to
change the rules illegal never loses the
game well in a Mike comer tournament
it's intense chest anything could happen
oh my Michael Pinkett chef is the winner
of this game unbelievable finish with
Dennis through there
navigating that opening with this King
but just oh my god he was so nervous
that was a problem you know what does
this time second seal and he was a piece
up and then two pawns and the deponent
was on f7 he just wanted to go craziness
for the checkmate so he had it in hands
yeah tragedy strikes once again for
Dennis through well I think Mike comer
should be ready to interview Michael
Pugachev without any further delay why
don't we head back over to the
tournament hall back with the winner
Michael Pugachev advanced against Dennis
LaRue again it seems like you really
have that get kids number so you really
had them and like in a stranglehold
early then you let them off the hook
I mean what was that about I had no idea
but uh in the end Dennis isn't that good
of a player that's why I took the win
the one hey take them any way you can
get them actually I think you had a win
much earlier I guess we'll have to roll
the videotape when he takes rook takes
d5 you could take back with a check
instead of taking the night you can just
take the rook and it's his kings on f3
with Chuck and it's a much much cleaner
victory but hey take them how you can
get them right well how what are your
thoughts about playing a club manager
and co-creator of intense chess jonathan
Schwantz in the next round
I'm excited I'm feeling pretty confident
so all right well you've already
guaranteed yourself $75 so
congratulations for that and we'll see
how you do moving forward
all right what a game what a victory
what intensity we're definitely feeling
it here in the studio our hearts are
breaking for it we have to be from like
two three hot drinks oh no it feels
better is going to be feeling the pain
of that loss for a while I think yeah
more intense chess yet to come though
this is only two games out of the first
four in this extreme eight of course
Michael Pugh yep now advancing on to the
Furious four he will face Jonathan
trance in the semi-finals but now the
devastating national master Julian Pro
Laco archbishops MVP is playing against
Tracy Stuart this is one to look out for
definitely Tracy coming it as a bit of
an underdog here but I wouldn't write
her off just but she's been training
alone she's they sure have regained the
club reading books playing games yes yes
she's got this tactics book and she's
just working through it every day you
know and that can work wonders for your
chess game exactly all right well we're
ready to go / why don't we throw out
back to Mike comer in the tournament
hall here and today national master
Julian Pro LICO also world champion with
the st. Louis Archbishop's of the pro
chess league all right against Tracy
story so let's see what Tracy can do as
we see and legal moves in the game and
if they could happen go ahead and start
it up and we see the handshake here from
the two players Tracy starts the clock
here we go you for a five matter 396 to
be should be five the Spanish real up is
very professional g6 not the main line
isolated so Tracy starting a lot
so now d4 striking in the center you
you're gonna take back you gotta take on
d4 probably and then there are some
ideas with Bishop g5 he goes from Bishop
d7 g7 and I hear actually Tracy of
course a regular at the ladies night
here at the Chess Club and I think
they've been going over this opening
something some home cooking from Tracy
she knows what she's doing yeah it's
five from Julian hitting this night now
you gotta go probably to e7
that's the most natural square
can you come to d4 here is this possible
you could come to d4 actually yeah that
she comes to seven instead 87 and then
this Bishop on b5 is not doing much now
stopping the a6 at the moment
d6 opening the position now she takes
Queen takes c6 Black has to develop this
Knight frontier but it's not easy
because the e5 4 is actually hanging so
maybe you have to go knight c6 here now
that you protect a 5 and then hoping to
go queenie 7 in the next move it
definitely some untangling to do for
black here yeah you know black of course
two Center pawns to one that's nothing
to write off yeah I'm that you don't
want to go f6 here because you're
working a lot the the a to g8 diagonal
so 8 c6 from Tracy oh we're ready for
five Shak Knight c3 defends the bishop
trying to go for the b5 bishop but then
Jonathan Julian Julian in this case
Jonathan protects the d5 Bishop Queen
hanging and then attacks rook and also
is 14 Bishop d7 oh and I think we did
the Queen she only is laughing a bit
joking around the g77 but Bishop takes
d7 Czech wins the Queen Queen takes g7
was also possible this is game over for
Trey's you still do it just a queen for
free Tracy down to 30 seconds and losing
the Queen here early on in this position
not not much to be done
Tracy just trying to find a way but
there's only one option you have to take
this bishop and then the Queen will fall
on a5 yeah so we should takes Queen a5
and this is game over 12 seconds on the
clock for Tracy 10 seconds affair tape
but now that the Queen still falls yeah
she's going to be 77 now maybe white
will just develop and get this dark
squared Bishop into the game
Oh or get castled yeah sure castles
natural move
and this is smooth sailing here for
Julian yep and okay b-66 it's the Queen
he's not gonna blunder the Queen Queen
III been in this e seven night some
threats on the dark squares coming King
back to e8 now black should get the
pieces in the game maybe five no Knight
f6 maybe today retakes there's 95 coming
on the board on e5 94 94 so the d6 where
is really tasty - so she's there's only
one good score 94 on the board I'd have
696 it's all coming down she's playing
for daily gotta move like yes she's so
the previous game valid strategies it
worked quite well for Michael Julian out
Queen d6 threatening Knight f6 and Queen
d7 checkmate you do Tracy stop it it's
not easy
my g8 maybe rook d8 is the best move
here for me the funniest one at least
yeah 98 still stops the checkmate but
okay time juicer and Tracy has actually
flagged well Julian notice or he's too
caught up in the intensity of the game
oh and he's pointed at the clock I
believe the players have noticed after
the handshake the result is official
Julian Pro ACO winning early on here in
round one that one may be a much-needed
break from the intensity yeah we were
really feeling we're still feeling it
for Denis Leary I think but Julian
advances on to the final four but now
coming up next actually is one of our
most exciting matchups but before we go
to that of course Julian pralaya
advancing and I think Mike comer is
going to get him in for a quick
interview okay thinking somebody review
okay
the result was probably exactly as you
expected huh yeah I mean I guess I I
don't I mean yeah I guess big favorite
so you advance you'll either play GM Ken
West or the mystery man who could it be
find out coming up next all right Julian
advancing on there of course as Mike
mentioned this next game is a bit of a
mystery to everybody
GM can west of course GM in quotation
marks they will be facing our mystery
player of the event and I'm getting word
maybe perhaps Mike comer actually knows
who the mystery man is why don't we
throw it back to him
in just a moment whenever he is ready
and he can introduce our mystery final
player will it be Magnus will it be Fabi
will it be me would it be you maybe
nobody knows let's find out who could it
be the mystery man please reveal
yourself that's right the mystery final
player all along it was Mike comer my
comer is the final man here in this
event and here we see Ken West getting
things started we form unfazed by the
big reveal how will Mike handle this
okay he's already thinking now what to
play with the black pieces c5 this is
silly of my Mike a grassy player let's
see what kind of CC Liam 96 maybe the
Rosalie Mihir with Bishop b5 the opens
hitting them with d4 it's maybe
something quieter maybe Mike's not a
weari is with Magnus Carlsen Mike my
brake cylinder with d5 a la pin like of
course the 1998 missouri high school
state champion playing in this event
and d5 has Ken West thinking already
he's already delving into that time make
a little bit d3 yeah this does not look
the most normal yeah the most
aggressively yes we're gonna reach a man
game which is actually quite interesting
for white here so bad the C 2 square
works quite nicely for the way King yeah
we've seen these kind of positions for
example in a game between Magnum scales
and number Telegraph with opponent g6
actually so it's pretty similar to those
chrome folds but now he should be
YouTube just protecting f3 worked yet
from Mike it's the Queen King no illegal
move just yet
mm-hmm and west getting developed and
yeah the game is gonna come to see - yes
Mike a little bit shaky already yes he's
feeling the intensity of his own time
format you think's getting developed it
before I move I can't ripping open the
bodies yeah bit or just a blunder see
these is cbcb and now Bishop takes me
for maybe Ken wanted rook b1 trying to
find activity over here yeah but you
know this King now all of a sudden is C
to square it doesn't look so safe to go
back probably to c6 and then I would say
that black is perfectly fine here it's
just a healthy porn app we should take
that three intermediate move now Mike
wants to go to d3 probably G takes f 3
and now Knight d3 actually looks good
targeting the f2 pawn threatening a fork
on F 293 on the board Mike let's go of
the piece B white we'll take this night
yeah you're gonna protect f2 either did
you play drunk f1 or you take on d3
right so I don't see any other way not
to lose the game immediately rook e1 so
hit manage this so now there is a fourth
kind of - let's say you see Mike finds
it Knight have two on the board
this King must move and then the rook on
h1 will fall yes there is a way to track
this night maybe maybe with King f1 and
King G to just to keep fighting maybe
clean up one and King g2 and then you
get this exchange at least this
disappears now this is not on h1 rook d7
expensive
yes actually Bishop b5 Eastside real
friend now my goodness
we should be fighting another turnaround
for example in 87 just loses Bishop c5
oh wait oh grabs the night he brings it
to f6 instead of oke 7 a little bit
better it's still there's some
compensation Shaq is 97 a night c4 for
example I need to go 95 night c4 I don't
like this move because there's no check
anymore now black can develop the bishop
and has King f8 in the event of a check
yes that's right but my comer is
thinking here what's he going to do he
does grab that Bishop puts it on to c5
and now black will Castle comfortably I
think this night even finding an escape
route this through f2 exactly solve
takes takes and the whites
I wrote down so it's like simply castles
and this is looking nice for my comer
here maybe Bishop f12 go Bishop g2 at
this point they should try to get this
Knight back I don't know black just
needs to activate his remaining pieces
now ok 7 it's going to push the a pawn
back ok a putting a stop to that now you
gotta take that broken e8 and then the
pony 3 is also falling rook c7 route
takes a 3 and also you've got to move
the knight from e3 maxi for attacking
the rook and a spooky one check ok one
check looks nice and the knight f2 will
come and this Knight is finding its way
out of the h1 square so team d2 and the
other rogue is coming to the action to
stir up d8
there's also night f2 is Kenny was there
the name of a rapper hearing I'm not to
my knowledge there's Leona Ken West I
know that's his real name
I think so many people in the YouTube
channel can tell us but I think it's on
kenny west kanye west yeah kanye west of
course very famous artists but now just
ken here for us ok
and now f4 on the board for Wyatt he
doesn't look like a rapper actually yeah
he's got a pretty stylin hat yeah
there's bishops there at night g4 now
the king is in check running out of
squares this Bishop does capture maybe
white will go for some crazy idea like
f5 bring the King into h6 and try to
make some checkmating threats f5 s six
kina for Kiki 5 ki netic checkmate 96
times for comment
there's your okay three rookies really
just brothers a true knight takes it to
nine takes a three is good for this no
okay so it's just going for the pawn on
h2 it was really gonna checkmate there
checkmate in one move yes rookie one was
checkmating one moon that's okay Mike
doesn't need that he's got an extra hook
maybe 96 now from what huh okay and I
just have received some good news here
group f8 Mike wins this game he will be
conducting an interview with himself
that'll be a sight to see definitely
rooting for that to appear Luke afraid
the most active move I've ever seen
right yeah Mike staying comfortably
ahead on time with 50 seconds left in
his bank take the pawn on g4 come on in
low take the pawn on g4 they're gonna do
it take that takedown can take the pond
s5 oh my gosh what is this is trying to
find a route for his skin but it's not
gonna be enough you see G takes that
five you don't have any nozzle enough
pieces to to make blacks opponent here
maybe can we go for some 97 to c5 trying
to take a 6 maybe it's going for those
tricks g3 Mike doesn't care about the f8
rook and then he's just going to promote
rooks II want covering g1
okay definitely a lot going on for Ken
here but this night still has not moved
from the age 1 square yes
G to its pawn getting closer and now
maybe route do you wanna be fun is
played it's unclear how black will try
to get rid of this rook on g1 here so da
drew k-8 Mike saves the stretch from
capture of course black is completely
weighted right
yes but anything could happen we saw
worse occur over the board with Dennis
Larew against Michael Pugachev illegal
moves do end the game there's always a
chance here for Ken West bring the mag
back to c5 for the defense I'd see 593
can dipping down now into this time Bank
just 19 seconds left
nice player trying to help those species
of course checkmate and one was
available for Mike earlier maybe he's
kicking himself h3 wins another piece
rook h3 check and then the knight on d3
is hanging in you do have to be slightly
careful though rook h3 king f4 but
there's no spell use no the g5 g 5
squared is available we do see Rick h3
okay King maybe this is another stone
mating try well actually it is but now
how do you get rid of the rook yeah rook
takes c3 I wanted to take him gives
another check another check and now he's
going hrough k1 and take their t1 group
probably king d 191 still no no take c3
no let go Mike comer pause as the clock
declares a win on illegal move and we
see the handshake here Mike comer is the
winner in this final match of the first
round of eliminations of course AHA a
single elimination tournament there are
no second chances here we saw Dennis the
root lose his big chance to advance in
this tournament after losing in a
heartbreaking finish to michael Pugachev
in this first round of play and uh well
I'm sure I'm certainly eager to see this
but I think Mike comer will need to be
himself will interview himself and I
believe will interview Ken West as well
on their previous match so why don't we
throw it back to them in our playing
area I'm here with the winner of the
game michael comer and of course ken
west yeah my beat of GM but I don't
think I'm going to be national master
Julian if I play like that I think you
had a shot earlier in the game where you
play Bishop to b5 check did you were you
thinking anything along those lines at
all apparently well I mean this was a
fun experience for you you know you got
$25 um have you ever played in times
chest before no and what surprised me is
Michael and Julian we're talking about
how got the feeling like blitz at the
end because again I never felt that I
felt like it was you know I looked down
oh I got 37 seconds but I never felt
like I do in a blitz game where I'm just
who are you making mistake like that
earlier exactly yeah I mean even with 37
seconds on there with that 10 second
actually clock it looks like you have
all the time in the world until that
10-second evaporates then it's like well
thank you so much for for playing and
enjoy the $25 congratulations to Mike
comer they're winning the game in
interviewing himself of course our
mystery final player is the 1998
Missouri high school state champion Mike
coming and he advances to the next round
of play why don't we take another look
at our bracket and see where things sit
I mean this round ended we have to say
that two games finish there by illegal
moves yes
two of yes and one of those games you
know Mike ofcourse was already winning
his position but Dennis LaRue throwing
away a win there yeah with that illegal
move that really hurt we see now our
furious four they're ready to fight here
we see Jonathan schranz will be taking
on Michael Pugachev Michael a second
chance at life after that miracle win
against Dennis LaRue and of course he
has now defeated Dennis the roux
mm-hmm again Jonathan trance still
famous for drawing a Cara Nakamura in a
Simon and losing to me and April but
we'll see if he can take down Michael
ticket chef in advance to the finals
these two players I think this is
shaping up to be another competitive
match so I I saw you a match actually
against yes yeah he was preparing so
hard you know yeah I have to say of
course Jonathan doing some very serious
preppin think you were talking over
Berlin positions with him but in blitz
that's where it started to fall apart
frames we'll see how he handles these
intense time Kendrick intense time
controls of course we've yet to see this
but if a game does end in a draw we go
to an arm again I'm gonna shoot one of
those yes
let me get met with almost no time on
the clock for either player mm-hmm
well I believe we are just about ready
to go back to the playing area and let's
see my comer start off the action once
again alright we are in the final four
Jonathan
against Michael pugachev will be the one
to kick us off all right Pikachu started
up we see the handshake there from
Michael as he starts the clock Jonathan
once again choosing d4 we see a repeat
of the last game so far Knight c3 Knight
f6 so C takes D both players following
the same path Bishop g5 been in the net
again so same game perhaps Michael was
paying attention to this first round
Knight B to d7
many positions who want to go 9 f8
straightaway but normally you protect d5
with c6 earlier let's see well he watch
any way to take advantage for white
though yeah Queen c2
okay normally you go eight six first but
okay matter three and finally C finally
six makes me a little less anxious for
blacks position actually you can never
go eight six because there is Bishop g6
so many people try eight four here not
so sure Ruby one look b1 some subtleties
from white here want to push this pawn
all the way up the board before b5 and
then try to take on c6 and then attack
and a quickness yeah we see a slightly
different approach from wait here than
in the last game he brings this knight
to f3 and it's going for the standard
minority attack I love h4 now it's
really interesting social castle and b4
yeah the standard way of playing its
time-honored strategy of the minority
attack on the Queen side playing very
solid Jonathan now here now you could
actually play a six this is a move that
normally black does here so I know there
to force a four and then when black
sorry when white manages to go b5 at
least you can take a b5 and then you get
the the a open five yes the open a file
for the rook some counter play on the
Queen side as well but Michael just
allowing b5 immediately if white chooses
yep no age three
you should h g4 sorry yes but you know
this h3 move it it creates some some
tender spots you know in White's camp
this Bishop on c8 could be sacrificed at
some point definitely see rookie a black
bringing this Knight to e4 maybe but b5
already on
boy yeah and now it's hard to play here
with with the black pieces maybe Bishop
d7 and play passively but then B take c6
and then 9 84 84 is his choice maybe he
wants Queen f6 with the ideas of Bishop
takes h3 yeah also Knight g5 ideas
95 ideas and then when you remove this
every night that could be some night h4
comments I'm definitely buying the Kings
side for black hair yeah attack a lot of
come to play for black here on the King
said definitely you have to play
dynamically here with the black pieces
so that YC 6 will be falling so not a
four runs the time but this moves a
piece away from the center away from the
Kings side I don't know how I feel about
this move yeah what if Queen f6 from
black enough six you protect c6 and then
you're threatened actually Bishop takes
a tree sin if this Knight moves away
there's night age for Knight g5 oh I
really liked your Queen f6 move also we
should d 7 but then this allows rook b7
which is very and I know I'm reaching
see reaching for the F pawn so one thing
is come only 26 seconds she said d7 lose
7 come very very annoying now look to
the 7 run active move now rooks e1 deal
like Queen f6 yeah six or even nine h4
straight away why not manage for I think
Michael's playing on the wrong side of
the board here he's trying to create
threats of c5 but it's just not going to
be achievable route b7 no this rook gets
active and now what to do about night c5
he likes but then okay 7 just went upon
right okay then not c7 is coming yes
thank you fine c5 both ideas we see
night b5 to just take take it and then
with the night I see fight exactly and
this is looking devastating there's also
Queen takes seats maybe to trade off
take pieces okay b7 simple chest from
Jonathan still night c5 are going to
appear on the board Knight b6 as well
okay you could try now 96 and 95 back
soon but then you will be forcing him to
take a be five senior p8 it takes big
stakes
and okay at least there's no acting rook
anymore in the seventh ranked likes
starting to untangle a little bit I mean
now has lost upon I'm now Bishop c8 and
then finally Queen f6 by midnight it for
but then you have no more lost some
pieces along the way
Michael reaching for this night he is
getting devastatingly low on time 16
seconds teen sex 6 now this is just a
from there 97 I'm Bishop b5 just wins a
game on the spot well Jonathan see it
you just know it doesn't see use on g6
so do see giving away this Bishop or
simplifying and now blacks gonna have a
lot of chances for sure
yes white certainly better in the Sun
game should probably win but it's not so
easy no it's just a pawn down at Queen
d6 you should really take this pawn is
Knight a seven ideas but then there's 97
I can take it at yes yeah somehow
working okay it maybe get active
but then knight c6 and then i will be
fine that's the success wins yeah in
1965 then too many poems for free here
even rook air-five available for white
to keep this a pawn on the board as well
yeah 94 we see
rook da check trading off the rooks and
this is as simple as it gets
in a knight endgame this is game over
guys definitely black missing some
chances for counter play but he'll play
on this endgame of course sometimes
miracles happen twice might we see a
sneaky Knight check I know Jonathan
personally very much struggles with the
sneaky Knight checks so we'll see if he
falls victim one-to-one here today okay
but now these 21 threatening in Knight
c3 check those keen d3 and three the
only square is a three night a three
played the key moment was when he went
black blade at rook c8 it was not
necessary you could have started with
Queen f6 you said before on the board
white is doing just going to push these
pawns
all the way to victory five I'm gonna
have g6 22 and give me that baby yes so
many puns it's unstoppable white might
win this position without a knight yep
but
with the night on the board it's going
to be simple looking advances g3 no
entry squares for that king and finds a
huge win for Jonathan's trance advancing
to the finals with that win over Michael
Pugachev Michael of course you know
struggled a bit in the first round found
a second chance at life after he
captured Denis LaRue's King but now
against Jonathan he does fall once again
this is intense chest just to react
splain the format the game the the time
control for these games is game in one
minute but with a 10 second delay on
each turn so the players have 10 seconds
to gather their thoughts before they
make a move and then they can dip into
that one minute time Bank for when the
going gets tough but why don't we take
it back over to Mike comer with an
interview with the winner
Jonathan chance well it's always good to
win but it doesn't seem like it was as
thrilling as a victory as the last time
around yeah I mean it was still it's
always a very tough game some I'm just
happy to be in the finals and what I'm
really hoping for is I get to see Mike
comer in the finals that's what I'm
cheering for now I wonder why is it
because you'd have a much better chance
of winning the $500 first-place prize
well I've played you and I've played
Julian so I think it's a pretty clear
choice I remember so you got my big
support
I remember one game we drew where I
played like the count and the Duke and
you played like Morphy but I still
managed the draw so hopefully I'll play
a little bit better than that against
Julian any advice for me against Julian
yeah with him I mean it's you got to
just go fast you got to trust yourself
you got to be confident and you got to
crush this guy you can do it alright
that sounds like me let's do this thing
alright alright Mike with that interview
with Jonathan Jonathan advancing to the
finals it's all down to this next game
to determine Jonathan's opponent of
course our mystery man Mike comer in
this tournament won his first round game
and now he faces the tournament number
one seed Julian Pro Lake oh you can Mike
upset the tournament favorite and
advance to the finals in his own
tournament format perhaps he's just more
experienced yeah and we'll see Julian
crack under the pressure okay
you know I wanted to I want
to their hairdresser yes I probably sure
to ask my care where he goes normally
because yeah Mike rockin the blonde hair
well of course dyeing it once again I
think quite recently looking good Mike
well why don't we go back to the
tournament area and see this game gets
started you got to see my hair got to
see my hurt alright its nemesis versus
nemesis to see who advances to the
finals at the play Jonathan shruts any
last word good luck I'll take it all
right we see Julian wishing my cluster
as his final words before Mike tries to
take come on and we see Julian just
playing a center stage for Mike coming
after him on the Kings side
age 35 sacrifice opening up the h-file
d-flat hits the spawn at age three he's
just gonna be this is just gonna be a
masterpiece Bishop takes a tree
and he plays it Bishop h3 on the board
Bishop takes h3 rook takes h3 and now
why probably defense the t5 phone
exactly white with a big advantage in
the center but can he compete with the
activity of this h3 rook be high from
Mike striking at every moment too weak
in the center extremely creative chess I
would say Julian shaking his head he
doesn't know what to do Knight g5 is
this way oh no Mike you're oh he's
reaching for the rook okay he's pointing
there d7 square I don't know why I don't
know what's going on he's grabbing the
rook though maybe look h4 gets a counter
play on the fourth-ranked no rook back
to a jaw it's the play solid now after
retreat now he wants to go back to AJ
why don't you keep my pieces back I'll
freshen the h2 you pawn from far away
this is a checkmate threat for you oh
well almost with Queen takes f7 being
threatened yeah I'm also d6 could be in
the air right because the a8 rook is
hanging actually yes so what will Mike
do now I should have come to h6 so we
had rook f6 there I think
we see the knight f6 now d6 like you
mentioned just c6c6c6 maybe 97 or still
nothing so bad
mike is going all-in in this game and we
see three three on the chest protecting
the pawn chain so the fire is gonna be
very well protected here in this
position right now at the open G file
versus black with the open H file B
takes c4 plate black needs to develop
his pieces somehow yeah but it's
extremely tough now because you can
never play E is six so maybe by a g7
this F a bishop from g6 and Bishop g7
maybe maybe maybe you get checkmate in
two moves here looking for C's no Knight
bt7 from my comer Knight c3 off the back
rank this is to the center Knight be
five maybe coming with Bishop f4 yeah be
sure before short Castle even Knight b6
e for good move like really fighting for
the light squares in the center so maybe
you go to protect c4 now with Queen e2
or queen d3 they look natural to me we
need to play you need to play and how to
develop now maybe Queen d7 and long
castle plain I'm striking immediately c6
on the bow
Mike wants to open this D file play
Queen takes d4 yep and then C 3 is under
attack wait to see chess from Mike and
probably is it's all bad but yeah looks
he's trying making making threats asking
Julian the tough questions
Julie now dipping into his time Bank
down here 30 seconds of course not black
is threatening to take care of on c5
what to do hmm Julian isn't sure yeah
down on time a second snap for both
players route b1 now she takes d5 Black
is fine yet that's a pawn black is
completely fine now indecision I suspect
for Knight c4 connect c4 e6 Bishop e7
I need black manages to do that then it
would be even better in this position I
would say moments away from get short
castles
six or even Queen c7 just threatening
checkmate than h2 money six is reaching
for this rookie eight I don't like that
super 14 or v8 was tutorial movement
because now you take on be one group
takes me one and Ruby it is coming
no Roxie eight me GA could be the move
now but after Ruby seven
what is so active there in that position
and after a six you can even take on a
six in many positions with the night
from g5 Mike down to nineteen seconds he
has to make a move
come on my rupee one rupee one and then
let's see how he stops 97-95 just wins
95 just wins because Knight c7 is a
threat then I don't see forest hanging
this Jeff game over I don't know maybe
no nothing works this is just game and
Mike going to use the remainder of his
time here try to find a way out but it's
just not there maybe e55 I don't trust
it but there's nothing that's not going
to do this at night on c4 Knight to c7
I'm Knight xf7 oh that's simply not an
idea and we see it from Julian 97 Queen
takes thee seven now forest yeah it's
gonna take it I'm even then I don't see
four it's also trucked root gates to
boom Oh like with two seconds on the
clock Bishop takes H to a very long
distance move from Julian Mike just
trying to find some way to give check
maybe hoping for the illegal move
strategy that we've seen prevail thus
far today Knight takes c6 from Julian
and Mike's time dwindles mr. Bates for
now it's going to sacrifice not Bishop
tuner
it just makes f2 threat will we see it
will we seen my go for the bishop takes
f2 idea and he does on Julian does not
fall for his tricks
Julian very professional if Mike wins is
when he's in check I'll quit chess me
too
night out of six played one second
o'clock
anything could happen Queen d7 only move
and now Knight takes g7 check King d8
and the end is near
yeah Queen c7 is checkmate in the next
move nothing to be done
a5 Queen c7 and this game is over
Mike Falls - Julian Pro leggo in this
intense chess match up of course a very
competitive game there not a no let me
expected destroy this sea taxi fight he
was ok Mike oh this crazy Mike pulling
it together H 5 H 4 H 3 and not the
worst opening ever played yeah Julian of
course look getting it done when he
needed to finding the play finding the
check meeting threats and dodging Mike's
tricks with Bishop takes f2 as he needed
to why don't we throw it back to Mike
comer in the playing hall where he is
going to interview his competitor Julian
Pro lekha alright so have you ever seen
that opening before yeah I played all
the time and bullets I mean honestly
that was my preparation all right yeah
you just thought I would go berserk and
it almost paid off for me
as Julia pointed out it I was thinking
about doing the old trick where if if
when I play rook b8 you take and then I
take and then we're taking with the
Queen and then yeah usually oh he's just
on b8 just threatening so if I would
have just played Queen c7 initially we
might have a we might have a more
competitive game but you know like plate
like you have like a playable position
no no this is open I mean yep well you
think I'm a nerd whether I put my night
on h6 or f6 probably not I was
definitely winning in either case I mean
I played like poorly later like be
threes probably just really stupid but
yeah I mean Queen c7 definitely would
have oh the game would have been
interesting there also there was like
some like East 60th and Link Bishop
before I mean like like I like some real
play in that game so yeah I'm there b3
move I mean it it's good because it
didn't let me do what I wanted to do and
if you kind of playing there
pone instead of the position just trust
me on it all right so we'll have you
don't have much time to think
you got to play Jonathan for the $500
but congratulations on making it to the
finals thank you
all right no breaks in the action here
Julian coming fresh off that win against
my comer now the finals of the
tournament are finally here we see the
number one seed and the number two seed
getting the job done meeting all of
their games to advance these finals it
will be national master Julian Pearl
Aiko against Jonathan's trance and I
believe Jonathan getting the white
pieces are you sure yes Jonathan the
white pieces yes Jonathan with the white
pieces but in the regulations of the
tournament we read that the high girl
highest seeded player gets the white
pieces but I believe the seeds were done
randomly not by rating but it just so
happens jonathan pulled the number one
seed in the random drawing and so he
will be getting the white pieces in
these finals against Julian why don't we
take one last look at that final bracket
see where we stand here coming into this
last round we see Jonathan Krantz and
now of course Julian Pro Lego will join
him in the final showdown
and it appears life before your eyes of
course Jonathan shreds all in loser
and Hikaru Nakamura draw can he win a
chess game here in the finals to defeat
Julian Pro Lego and become the intense
chess champion netting himself $500 a
very serious first place prize and well
without further ado it's time let us see
the final game of intense chest 2019
with Mike comer in the tournament hall
welcome to the finals of the $1,000
national chest day intense chest
invitational hopefully this will
revolutionize the game of chess I
encourage everybody at home to try it at
least once one minute with a 10 second
delay and see what it's all about
congratulations to the finalists
Jonathan Trott's and Julia Pro LICO for
making it that far and you may begin
all right we see the handshake between
the players
d for again Jonathan very consistent
staying with the same repertoire okay
now we see some kind of sloth here yes
Julian a sloth player at heart C d5
Knight f3
me65 one of the most difficult lines yes
after detects e4e for this is just crazy
but he goes for 90 d7 and then we
transpose to the Queen's Gambit yes of
course the semi sloth now yeah we see h6
on the board Bishop Age 4 black develops
to e7 just simply unpinning normally you
want to go here Queen c2 root d1 Bishop
d3 now it's time to take on c4 at some
point to send some b5 Bishop d7 ideas of
course the triangle system from black
putting all of his pawns on those light
squares we see C takes D now you're
preventing D takes d4 black to casters
for tonight yeah keeping a 8h one
diagonal open for the light squared
bishop okay and now go rook c1 or quincy
to rook e1 on the board not simply
because there was Knight d4 yeah it's
natural to take with their work here to
put some pressure on the c6 phone let's
say after rook c3 Bishop e7 Bishop c4
maybe there should be something maybe I
can get away with c5 pretty quickly here
but now B should be 4 right so roots yet
Queen a4 or Queen c2 and then Brooke c1
sufficient b1 instead we should be 1
he's going for it to mate but now c5 and
then I would say black is fine it's this
5:23 how is black responding to the main
matter of six I guess
Zenzi takes 95 we should have three
Queen c2 even Queen c2 and now maybe g6
it's solid enough because of the
detoxified you can just by taking the e4
square
maybe we'll see this Knight route itself
into that hole in White's position yeah
I think I would like maybe you can take
on c5 and then played before because
after 94 days rook c7 so detective
Arnett takes b4 this looks very very
good for black there's some Bishop f4
you should be for it immediate move
that's right not sure what's going on
Queenie to Jonathan's solid choice of
course the downside f5 this ye v square
is now very weak for black and so he
compensates by moving this pawn forward
getting rid of his back
on b5 all right move good look looks
good actually
White has his choice of ways to capture
you can take on c5 he can take on e5 but
either way blacks pieces well nice 65
and then I would say black is better
here Knight takes e5 e 4 might be coming
for black and the knight c3 idea is
always in the position of body for
because I like my bishop from v7 target
in f3 oh yes but I don't know maybe Rick
FC won of course dodging Bishop a6 also
also be for it could be a threat now
because then rook c7 is coming so maybe
just root CA to counter play to counter
the rooks on the see if I like 85 85
looks good basics anyway
yeah just Queen c2 or 21 Queen c2 looks
good I think II four might be his plan
he's aiming for this d3 square huh Ebert
gives the nice d4 square exactly that
NATO differs it's from Texas you place
de for anyways I'm not 94 right just
windy one and again if I manage to get
this be 53 Queen dy when do you want to
Queen d2 I don't know where what is
black doing with the bishop yeah I'd be
on the C file maybe but it's getting too
late now white controls this file very
nicely yeah I know before it's actually
a real threat in this position because
you go to e six there's Queen b3 and
then there's a massive beam from a 2 to
g8 Julian now I think going to dip into
his time bank a little bit this is a
critical position definitely needs to
spend more or is his choice oh so now
before it's actually quite before on the
board yeah um it should be when I can
take on c5 right maybe back to d3 ship
docked back to d3
maybe c6 I'm full tuck and push that guy
and maybe even takes b6 and works c7
you're getting into the black camp yeah
b3 checked bishop takes a to maybe I
should take a TCU guarding the diagonal
yeah and c6 and this is of course
extremely SS yeah yeah so c6 aiming to
go c7 in the next move do block
with Queen c7 there's 96 I don't mind
White's position at all I think Jonathan
might be pressing quite nicely here
yeah but also black has this f3 idea
which is
very interesting yeah it's c6 on the
board
f3 f3 looks quite dangerous
there's also ideas of Queen g55 24.8
tree
it's dangerous I may be after every you
can't just take this problem with a
cheap one I don't know place 25 allowing
night east 6 what is the plan IT 686
queen g4 maybe 9 takes f8 runs into f3
so Queen g4 maybe just once
well there's 24 just wait there's a
queen on d1 guards g4 ah sorry this
whole this is just this is losing so
queen of 6 neck takes this exchange
sacrifice Queen f5 retakes
and now c7 serve on the board what is
black doing
maybe f3 was there was there F takes III
there with Queen of two ideas so it's
just an exchange hop for white here
exchange up for white threats on the
King though white must marry I would
just take on f4 here yes exactly so to
stop at three ideas and now maybe even
take either for just be careful not to
take them distribute across the screen
c1 check matrix we need six comes maybe
rook f8 here is an idea ok fate I didn't
actually check me yet you cannot green
everyone quick f1 we're getting late but
this is just this is just a it's
actually quite tricky for y to play now
goes what do you play maybe maybe f3
you takes f3 yeah but I know there's an
easy one check this looks dangerous f3
can you join a tree now Queen takes f2
keen h2
King h1 is played and now this e pawn
might be doing something that can I go
bishop f1 here
I should f1 threatens a shot mate
they're fatigued ring g4 g 4 don't look
at for ideas wow this is getting selfish
enough one winning ship a6
this cannot be right no sweetie just
just Queen yeah take off all the pieces
and then you cannot lose this game if
you're jonathan strands yeah and then
one important thing is to take with the
Queen at the end of the line yes because
if you take with the rook days perpetual
with Queen f1 and queen of four we see
Queen takes e4 and
stead yeah that's also natural with a
check and then protecting g2 and this is
just game over it's just game over
nothing to be done for Julian Pro Lacko
here yeah c8 is gonna come and you go to
resign you know root kept 7m7 maybe we
shall be seven nine the next wolf aiming
to go actually to checkmate
very dangerous ever should go seven it's
not easy
rook 3c to route the seats of through
there's Bishop takes G to group G one g1
is his choice hop up now I wanted to go
recast three here we're just going u7
I'm c8 right there's almost Bishop takes
g2 but the rook covers the f3 is square
so there's no perpetual check so
probably does he just game over yeah
this looks devastating this is just game
oh can you play rook takes also week at
five we get five working at five
Lucas fate now just Queen III yeah now
Queen a5 Queen f7 seven is his choice
he's trying to keep the game alive
Jonathan looking to trade Queens we did
he find still Queen f5 Queen d5 as well
and rook c8 but now the Queen trade
walked a black threats are gone
and this is looking to be a hopeless
ending now yep we should be game over
now Group D 700 T 8 seconds on the clock
648 King e7 rook takes see a bishop
takes ca if Julian can somehow
miraculously draw the son game he would
advance to an Armageddon playoff but
this should just be a win for whites ya
know the King comes okay a4 maybe yeah
and the King enters the game but 67
games live I guess I'm thinking a five
and then came before King a five there's
Bishop e6 I'm sure
winning the pawn endgame is his idea
okay
and Julian out of time out of pieces no
way out
for Julian here we say a humongous upset
from Jonathan
trance taking down Julian Pro liquor
swayed by the resins what an upset
in this final round of intense chess you
see Jonathan they're quite happy
drumming on the table definitely going
to be happy with the big win here your
intense chess champion in this inaugural
event is Jonathan France with a perfect
score of three and Oh surviving the
elimination bracket that's yeah what
impressive games it was from from
Jonathan as well defeating Julian in a
very competitive final round here well
okay looks like we're back up and do
we'll have an interview with a final
interview with Mike I believe Mike will
be ready to interview Judah
Jonathan's trance excuse me in the
tournament winner for the first year of
intense chess I'm here with the winner
of the $1,000 national chest day intense
chess invitational Jonathan shruts $500
winner how'd you do it well I listened
to the advice of Tracy I know she lost
to him in round one so I how can I
improve you know I'm thinking Tracy how
do I do this she gave me the best advice
she said you know develop your stuff and
then don't blend your pieces so I tried
to emulate that out there today well it
seemed to work out and thank you for
helping me create this great game
intense chess and hopefully it really
catches on and you think more events
like this more people will be playing it
yes I had no idea how this was actually
gonna turn out but I love this I'd love
to do this again not just based on the
result but it really is intense people
don't get it until you actually play it
but if you try this out once you know
we're getting down into the seconds here
it is it is intense you start to feel it
I feel like 10 seconds it feels like you
got a couple seconds you got to move
right and each game takes a lot out of
you and Tracy Ward to lean down I were
drooling down so I'm gonna take credit
for the victory - all right absolutely
all right Jonathan well well played a
well deserving champion number one seed
prevails
thank you very much all right all right
Jonathan trance your intense chest
winner
of course this inaugural thousand dollar
national chest day festival here is
coming to a close
congratulations once again to Jonathan
on a well-played event yeah what's a
nice event yes happy to be here thanks
to Mike comer
and Jonathan for organizing this event
bringing everybody together thank you to
all of our wonderful players for playing
such entertaining games and thank you
dear viewers for joining us this has
been our live coverage of the intense
chess tournament thank you all so much
for joining us we'll see you next time
here on the 60s club see you guys
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]